From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. There's this kind of therapy for trauma, victims of sexual assault, soldiers with PTSD, where instead of taking years and talking, and talking, and talking on some couch to a therapist with no end in sight, you basically knock it out, all the treatment in just 10 or 12 sessions.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。针对创伤、性侵受害者和患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的士兵，存在一种治疗方法：与其在治疗师的沙发上耗费数年进行无休止的谈话，不如通过短短10到12次疗程彻底解决问题。
Two weeks-- you can do it in two weeks. And it's effective. Studies have shown that. This therapy's been around since the '80s, but I think lots of people who might find it useful don't even know it's an option for them. Like, for instance, Jaime Lowe, who's a writer and reporter and a good candidate for this treatment.
两周——你两周就能完成。而且疗效显著。研究已经证实了这一点。这种疗法自80年代起就存在了，但我认为许多可能从中受益的人甚至不知道还有这种选择。比如，作家兼记者杰米·洛，她就是这种治疗的理想候选人。
I was sexually assaulted when I was 13, almost 30 years ago. And for most of those 30 years, I didn't really talk about it. Not because I didn't want to or need to, but because I didn't know how. And no one asked.
我在13岁时遭到性侵，那已经是快30年前的事了。在那30年里，我基本没谈论过这件事。不是因为我不想或不需要，而是因为我不知道怎么说。而且也没有人问过我。
Jaime Lowe decided to do a story where she would go through this therapy herself and record all of the sessions, which never happens. Like most therapy, usually this treatment is in private, not on the radio.
杰米·洛决定做一个专题报道，亲身尝试这种疗法并记录下所有的疗程，这种情况以前从未有过。像大多数心理治疗一样，这种治疗通常在私下进行，而不是在电台广播。
And hearing how it works, it really is kind of remarkable. My mom was a therapist. I've been in therapy. This is so different from what I have ever heard. And that's going to be our show today. We're going to hear it step by step, this sometimes life-changing process, and how that can happen so quickly.
听到它是如何运作的，确实相当了不起。我母亲曾是心理治疗师，我也接受过治疗。这和我听过的所有疗法都截然不同。这就是我们今天节目的内容。我们将一步步聆听这个有时能改变人生的过程，以及它是如何如此迅速地发生的。
A quick warning to listeners before we start about content. This story does mention the sexual assault of a teenager. Here's Jaime Lowe.
在开始之前，给听众一个简短的内容提醒。本故事提到了青少年时期遭受的性侵。下面是杰米·洛的讲述。
I thought because I didn't talk about the assault or even think about it much, everything was as resolved as it could be. But then after Donald Trump, and "grab them by the pussy," and Harvey Weinstein, and all of them, it's not that specific memories of the assault would pop up, I just felt immobilized, anxious, protective of my body. And I realized my sexual assault wasn't resolved at all.
我原以为既然我不谈论那次侵犯，甚至不去多想它，那么一切就算解决得尽可能好了。但后来在唐纳德·特朗普、“抓下体”言论、哈维·温斯坦以及所有人之后，并不是说我对侵犯的具体记忆会突然涌现，我只是感到无法动弹、焦虑、对自己的身体充满保护欲。我意识到我的性侵创伤根本没有解决。
Around this time, I heard about a therapy for sexual assault survivors, called Cognitive Processing Therapy, or CPT. A researcher described it to me as short-term inexpensive, practical, like learning a skill. The typical way to deal with trauma in therapy is to talk about the incident over and over, until it's less radioactive.
大约在这个时候，我听说了一种针对性侵幸存者的疗法，叫做认知处理疗法（CPT）。一位研究人员向我描述它为短期的、低成本的、实用的，就像学习一项技能。治疗创伤的典型方法是反复谈论事件，直到它不再那么具有杀伤力。
CPT does the same thing, but in a systematized way. It's all laid out in advance, and the same for everyone-- what you'll do in the first session, and the second, and the third, and so on. Each session is based on learning a skill and practicing that skill on a worksheet. You go over each element of the trauma, piece by piece, and try to see it differently. The goal is to change the story you've been telling yourself about what happened.
CPT做同样的事，但以一种系统化的方式。一切都是提前安排好的，对每个人都一样——你在第一次、第二次、第三次疗程等会做什么。每个疗程都基于学习一项技能并在工作表上练习。你要逐个梳理创伤的每个要素，并尝试从不同的角度看待它。目标是改变你一直以来对自己所发生之事的描述。
I got in touch with Dr. Debra Kaysen, a psychologist with a specialty in trauma therapy at the University of Washington School of Medicine. She and I started talking and e-mailing about CPT. It all seemed so different than the therapy I was used to-- my weekly talk sessions-- and I realized I wanted to try it.
我联系了华盛顿大学医学院的心理学家、创伤治疗专家黛布拉·凯森博士。我们开始交谈并互通邮件讨论CPT。这与我习惯的每周谈话疗法完全不同，我意识到我想尝试一下。
I've done a lot of therapy. After the assault, I had two manic episodes and was diagnosed bipolar. I've always been very open about mental illness. I wrote a book about being bipolar a couple of years ago. But even though that book is partly about my adolescence, I barely mention the assault. I've never dealt with it, I never wanted to-- in the book, in treatment.
我做过很多心理治疗。侵犯发生后，我有过两次躁狂发作，并被诊断为躁郁症。我一直对精神疾病持开放态度。几年前我写了一本关于躁郁症的书。但尽管那本书部分关于我的青春期，我几乎没提过那次侵犯。我从未处理过它，也从未想过要处理它——在书里或治疗中。
But now I was feeling the trauma more. I thought CPT might help me. I also thought, what if this could help lots of people? I asked Dr. Kaysen if I could record the sessions and play them on the radio. She checked in with colleagues-- a psychologist with an expertise in journalism, a journalism ethics professor-- to make sure we'd be able to have a therapeutic relationship while I was simultaneously doing a story about the therapy.
但现在我感到了更深的创伤。我觉得CPT可能会有所帮助。我也在想，如果这能帮助很多人呢？我问凯森博士我是否可以录下疗程并在广播中播放。她咨询了她的同事——一位擅长新闻学的心理学家和一位新闻伦理学教授——以确保在进行关于该疗法的报道时，我们仍能保持治疗关系。
After a lot of back and forth and establishing some basic ground rules, we set up our CPT boot camp-- 10 hour-long sessions over two weeks in Seattle. Usually CPT is one session a week for 12 weeks, but we decided to condense it. And early studies show this approach is effective. Last October, I flew out to Seattle.
在反复沟通并制定了一些基本准则后，我们成立了CPT训练营——在西雅图进行为期两周的10次一小时疗程。通常CPT是每周一次，持续12周，但我们决定浓缩它。早期的研究表明这种方法是有效的。去年十月，我飞往西雅图。
Session one, October 22nd.
第一次疗程，10月22日。
Excellent.
太好了。
Yeah. OK.
嗯。好的。
Yeah.
嗯。
I'm sitting with Dr. Kaysen in a generic room at the university clinic. I fail at setting up the recording equipment a few times, before getting it semi-right. I'm not a radio person.
我和凯森博士坐在大学诊所的一间普通房间里。我在设置录音设备时失败了几次，才勉强弄对。我不是搞广播的人。
So let me tell you a little bit about what we're going to do today. OK?
那么，让我告诉你我们今天要做什么。好吗？
OK.
好的。
So usually, today is a little more heavy on the psycho ed. It's going to be a little different than a lot of our other sessions. I'm going to be talking a lot.
通常，今天的内容会侧重于心理教育。它会和我们其他的疗程有点不同。我会说很多话。
OK.
好的。
OK? Which takes a little bit of the pressure off of you, maybe.
好吗？这可能会减轻你的一点压力。
OK.
好的。
Dr. Kaysen has a kindergarten teacher presence that makes me feel ready and OK. She starts the first session with me the way she would with anyone, by talking about sexual assault and PTSD. 50% of women who are sexually assaulted develop PTSD. That could mean symptoms like depression, anxiety, flashbacks-- some of the things I've actually been feeling when I hear the news.
凯森博士有一种幼儿园老师般的亲和力，让我感到准备好了，没问题。她像对待任何人一样开始了我们的第一次疗程，谈论性侵和PTSD。50%遭受性侵的女性会患上PTSD。这可能意味着抑郁、焦虑、闪回等症状——这些正是我听到新闻时实际感受到的。
Dr. Kaysen hands me a photocopied worksheet. Everything we're going to do, this entire therapy, is structured around these worksheets. I'll do them at my Airbnb. And when Dr. Kaysen and I meet, we'll go over them. Each set of worksheets will cover a new skill, and I'll master that before moving on to the next skill, which Dr. Kaysen will introduce at the end of each session.
凯森博士递给我一张复印的工作表。我们要做的每一件事，整个治疗过程，都是围绕这些工作表展开的。我会在爱彼迎（Airbnb）住处完成它们。当我们见面时，会一起回顾。每套工作表涵盖一项新技能，我会在进入下一项技能前掌握它，凯森博士会在每次疗程结束时介绍下一项技能。
The idea is, by the time we're done, I'll be able to do this on my own with any issue in my life. Dr. Kaysen explains my first assignment. Most of the worksheets have all sorts of boxes to fill in with answers. They look like badly designed forms you'd get at the DMV, but this first one is just a sheet of paper.
想法是，当我们完成时，我将能够独自应对生活中的任何问题。凯森博士解释了我的第一个任务。大多数工作表都有各种各样的格子需要填上答案。它们看起来就像你在车管所拿到的设计拙劣的表格，但这第一张只是一张纸。
What I want you to do is write at least one page on why you think that the sexual assault occurred. I do not want you to use this as an opportunity to write specific details about the event, OK? This is more writing about what you think caused the event.
我想要你做的是写至少一页关于你认为性侵是如何发生的。我不想让你借此机会写关于事件的具体细节，好吗？这是让你写写你认为导致了该事件的原因。
The phrase "caused the event" makes me uneasy, because as much as I intellectually believe that nothing specific really caused the event, there are things I still question. It's embarrassing that, after 30 years, I still might think it's my fault, but I do.
“导致了该事件”这句话让我不安，因为尽管从理性上我相信没有具体的什么导致了事件，但我内心仍有质疑的事。令人尴尬的是，30年后，我可能还是认为这是我的错，但我确实这么想。
I can tell you that the cause is going to be very hard for me.
我可以告诉你，谈论起因对我来说非常困难。
Yeah. Yeah, we talked earlier about what are the stories we tell ourselves.
是的。是的，我们之前谈到过我们告诉自己的那些故事。
Yeah.
是的。
It was this.
就是这个。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Right? The event happened because I took a shortcut. Right? The event happened because I had a drink. The event happened because I was wearing a short skirt. And sometimes people know that that's not why it happened, but sometimes those thoughts still haunt them. OK. There aren't any right or wrong answers. I want you to just vomit the ideas on the page.
对吧？事件发生是因为我走了捷径。对吧？事件发生是因为我喝了酒。事件发生是因为我穿了短裙。有时人们知道这不是原因，但这些想法仍然会困扰他们。好的。没有对错答案。我只想要你把脑中的想法倒在纸上。
That's my specialty.
那是我的专长。
Awesome. Then you'll do well.
太棒了。那你一定没问题。
I love vomiting out words.
我喜欢把文字倒出来。
That's awesome. That's what I want. All right.
太棒了。我想要的就是这个。好了。
OK, so.
好的，那么。
OK, any worries that you have about doing this?
好的，关于做这个你有什么担心吗？
Nope.
没有。
OK.
好的。
But of course, I'm worried. The thought of reliving the assault is terrifying. Even reading the one-sentence description of the assault during the audio recording of my book left me in tears. I rarely articulated the details out loud. I just don't know what will come up. I don't know what it's going to be like to dig in for the next two weeks.
但当然，我很担心。重温那次侵犯的想法太可怕了。即使在录制我的书的有声版时读到对侵犯的那一句描述，都让我泪流满面。我很少大声说出细节。我不知道会发生什么。我不知道在接下来的两周里深入挖掘会是什么感觉。
Session two. So what are you actually doing?
第二次疗程。那么你现在在做什么？
Right now?
现在吗？
Yeah.
对。
I'm totaling it.
我在统计它。
Can you describe the worksheet, actually?
你能描述一下这张工作表吗？
Yeah, absolutely. Happy to. So this is called the PTSD checklist.
当然。我很乐意。这叫做PTSD检查清单。
OK.
好的。
OK. And all it is a measure of how intense the symptoms of PTSD are.
好的。它只是衡量PTSD症状有多严重的一个指标。
Dr. Kaysen says we'll start all the sessions like this-- going over my PTSD symptoms and rating their intensity. How frequently have I been thinking of the trauma? Have I been dreaming about it? Reliving it? In the past 24 hours, how much have I been distressed by repeated disturbing and unwanted memories of the traumatic event? Each question gets a numerical value on a scale of 0 to 4, and Dr. Kaysen adds them up.
凯森博士说我们将像这样开始所有疗程——回顾我的PTSD症状并评估它们的强度。我多久会想到那次创伤？有没有做关于它的梦？重温它？在过去24小时内，我因反复出现创伤事件的令人不安和不想要的记忆而感到痛苦的程度如何？每个问题都有一个0到4的分值，凯森博士会把它们加起来。
And so what I'll do is I'll actually start graphing these and keeping track--
我实际上会开始画图表并追踪这些——
Cool.
酷。
--of them.
——它们。
I'm not sure how to answer these questions with a number, but I have the same problem when physicians ask me to rate pain on a scale of 1 to 10. After we go over my PTSD symptoms, Dr. Kaysen will ask me about my mood. Then we'll move on to the homework, what she calls the practice.
我不确定该如何用数字回答这些问题，但当医生让我用1到10的等级评定疼痛时，我也面临同样的问题。回顾完我的PTSD症状后，凯森博士会问我心情如何。然后我们将进入家庭作业，也就是她所谓的“练习”。
Most of each session we're going to spend actually reviewing the practice that you did over the day. OK?
大部分疗程时间我们将用来回顾你当天完成的练习。好吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
So for today, what we're going to do is we're going to actually start by going through the impact statement that you wrote.
所以今天，我们要做的实际上是从回顾你写的“影响陈述”开始。
The impact statement-- the one-page worksheet on why I think the assault happened. I wrote it before sunrise this morning, and it was, not surprisingly, really hard to write.
影响陈述——那张关于我为什么认为侵犯发生的单页工作表。我今天凌晨写完它的，不出所料，写起来真的很难。
So I'm going to have you read to me what you wrote.
那我要你把你写的读给我听。
OK.
好的。
OK?
好吗？
Uh, I was young, 13. And I don't think I knew much about actual human nature, friendliness, strangers. It's funny to think that I was not cautious about the very thing kids are always warned of-- strangers. I walked to my bus stop alone every morning. [TEARFUL] It was always early. [WEEPING]
呃，那时我很小，13岁。我觉得我不太了解人性、友善、陌生人。想到我竟然对自己总被叮嘱要防范的东西——陌生人——缺乏警惕，真是有趣。我每天早上独自走到巴士站。[泪流满面] 总是很早。[抽泣]
You're doing great, Jaime. Just stay with it.
你做得很好，杰米。坚持住。
[SOBS] There weren't many people, because it was Los Angeles and no one walks. I used to pass an alley and wave at a man. He was young, maybe late teens, early 20s. Every morning, I'd wave at him. He would walk up the alley. I would cross the alley. Or some mornings, I would walk down the alley against my mom's instructions. But we'd pass, and I'd always wave or smile, which is how I greeted everyone in the neighborhood.
[抽泣] 那里没什么人，因为是在洛杉矶，没人步行。我过去常经过一条小巷，向一个人挥手。他很年轻，可能十几岁到二十出头。每天早上，我都会向他挥手。他会走上巷子。我会穿过巷子。或者有时，我不顾我妈的叮嘱走过那条巷子。但我们经过时，我总是挥手或微笑，这是我在街坊邻里打招呼的方式。
It didn't seem like he should be any different. And in some ways, in retrospect, I feel like I overcompensated and was extra friendly and maybe invited him in, that my wave somehow signaled to him that this was something I wanted, that my friendliness was misinterpreted as desire. That I should have avoided him, [SOBBING] rather than interact.
看起来他不应该有什么不同。在某种程度上，回顾过去，我觉得我有点矫枉过正，太友好了，或许引狼入室，我的挥手不知怎么向他暗示了这是我想要的，我的友善被误解为渴望。我不该与他互动，[抽泣] 而应该避开他。
I break down, but I keep reading. Even though I'd followed Dr. Kaysen's instructions not to write down specific details of the event just yet, they were all coming back to me anyway.
我崩溃了，但我继续读下去。尽管我遵循了凯森博士的指示，先不要写下事件的具体细节，但无论如何它们还是都涌上来了。
You did an incredible job with that. You did an incredible job.
你做得太棒了。你做得太棒了。
Dr. Kaysen hands me a Kleenex box.
凯森博士递给我一盒纸巾。
That's OK, I don't need Kleenex.
没关系，我不需要纸巾。
Are you sure?
你确定吗？
Yeah, I'm really into the snot.
是啊，我真的很习惯流鼻涕。
I was going to say, I find sleeves work fine for me. OK. Is it OK with you if I take a look at it?
我本想说，我发现衣袖对我来说就够用了。好的。你介意我看一下吗？
Of course.
当然。
All right. So one of the things was a piece around your mom's instructions. Is that-- and I noticed that those emotions got a little more intense when you got to that.
好吧。其中一点关于你母亲的嘱咐。这是——我注意到当你谈到这一点时，那些情绪变得更加强烈了。
That was something that I didn't actually remember until I was writing it this morning. We were never really supposed to walk down the alley, even though it was closer to get to the bus stop.
直到今天早上写的时候，我才真正记起这件事。虽然走巷子去巴士站更近，但我们本来是不被允许走那条巷子的。
I tell Dr. Kaysen more about my mom's rule and how I broke it. She wonders if this might be a stuck point. Stuck points are the first skill introduced in CPT, and they might be the most important skill of all. In a sense, the entire project of CPT is finding stuck points, and then learning how to unstick them.
我告诉凯森博士更多关于我母亲的规定以及我是如何违背它的。她想知道这是否是一个“卡住点”。卡住点是CPT引入的第一项技能，它们可能是所有技能中最重要的一项。从某种意义上说，CPT的整个项目就是寻找卡住点，然后学习如何解开它们。
A stuck point is basically something you hold to be true, but might in fact not be true. A stuck point is a belief or a thought that's keeping you stuck in the PTSD, stuck in thinking that it's your fault, or that there's something you could have done to avoid it, or stuck in any number of upsetting or inaccurate or harmful ways of remembering what happened. They're so central to this process that Dr. Kaysen hands me a worksheet titled, Stuck Point Log.
卡住点基本上是你认为是真的，但实际上可能并非如此的想法。卡住点是一个让你陷入PTSD的信念或想法，让你陷入认为是自己的错，或者认为你可以做些什么来避免它的想法，或者陷入任何无数令人不安、不准确或有害的记忆方式中。它们在这一过程中至关重要，凯森博士递给我一张标题为“卡住点记录”的工作表。
OK. This is going to be a living document that you and I are going to share.
好的。这将是一个你我共享的动态文档。
We'll keep track of all my stuck points here, adding to the list as we identify new ones each session, and crossing them off as I work through them.
我们将在这里追踪我所有的卡住点，在每次疗程中识别出新的卡住点就添加到列表中，并在我克服它们时把它们划掉。
So I may be hearing a little bit of a stuck point, maybe, around like, I should've listened to my mom, or if I hadn't gone that way, it wouldn't have happened.
所以我可能听到了一点卡住点的端倪，也许是关于“我不应该那样做”或者“如果我不走那条路就不会发生了”。
I think it's more like if I hadn't waved, it wouldn't have happened.
我觉得更像是如果我没挥手，就不会发生了。
Perfect.
完美。
That actually feels more like--
这实际上感觉更像——
Yeah.
是的。
--what, um.
——什么，嗯。
So write that down. We're going to start keeping track of these as we find them.
把它写下来。我们一发现它们就要开始追踪。
OK.
好的。
So if I hadn't waved, it wouldn't have happened. OK. All right.
如果我没挥手，就不会发生了。好的。好。
Dr. Kaysen asked me what feelings are coming up.
凯森博士问我产生了什么感觉。
I mean, I hear the word shame associated a lot with things like this. And I feel like that would apply, but it doesn't feel like the right word. Like, it feels more just like I want to just shelter myself, and I want to just cocoon.
我的意思是，我听到羞耻感这个词常与这类事情联系在一起。我觉得这适用，但这感觉不是准确的词。就像，感觉更像是我想躲避自己，想躲进蚕茧里。
OK.
好的。
I think that I also just don't like that word. Like, I think that there's something shameful about shame. It's like-- I don't know.
我想我也不喜欢那个词。我觉得羞耻感本身是有某种令人羞愧的东西。就像——我不知道。
So I think that's going to be an important one for us to sort out, actually, because feelings aren't good or bad.
所以我认为这将是我们整理的一个重要方面，实际上，因为情绪没有好坏之分。
Right.
对。
Right?
对吧？
Isn't there another word, though?
不过，没有别的词了吗？
I bristle at the word "shame." I always have. There's no room for shame. It sounds weak to me. Like, if you have shame, you have something to feel shameful about. With shame comes softness, and vulnerability, and fragility.
我对“羞耻”这个词感到反感。一直以来都是。没有羞耻的余地。它对我来说听起来很软弱。就像，如果你有羞耻感，你就有了值得感到羞愧的事情。羞耻伴随着柔软、脆弱和虚弱。
So you will see these lovely worksheets. These are called ABC sheets. OK?
所以你会看到这些可爱的工作表。这些叫ABC表格。好的？
It's the end of the session, and ABC is the new skill. I'm supposed to fill in the A column with the activating event-- in my case, the sexual assault-- B with my belief or stuck point about the event, C with the consequence of that belief or stuck point. It's kind of clunky, but the idea seems to be to get you to see that your stuck points are not rational and that hanging on to these irrational stuck points has real emotional consequences, that continuing to tell yourself this stuff as fact makes you feel bad.
疗程结束了，ABC是新技能。我应该在A栏填入激活事件——就我而言，是那次性侵——B填入关于该事件的信念或卡住点，C填入该信念或卡住点的后果。这有点笨拙，但想法似乎是让你看到你的卡住点不是理性的，坚持这些非理性的卡住点会产生真实的情感后果，即不断地告诉自己这些事实会让你感觉糟糕。
Last thoughts, questions? How did this work for you today?
最后有什么想法、问题吗？你今天觉得怎么样？
Um, good. It was intense. I mean, I was like-- it was definitely-- I feel weirdly better, because I feel like we've started.
嗯，好。很强烈。我的意思是，我感觉——绝对是——我感到奇怪地好一些了，因为我觉得我们开始了。
We've started. All right, I'm going to make a copy of the impact statement. So I've got that, all right?
我们开始了。好的，我要复印一下影响陈述。我有那个了，好吗？
I think session two's done.
我想第二次疗程结束了。
I think we're done.
我想我们完成了。
Session three-- so this is hard for me to answer. Is the unwanted memory ...
第三次疗程——这个问题对我来说很难回答。是不想要的记忆……
I'm sitting with Dr. Kaysen going over the checklist of my PTSD symptoms. Did I have memories about the assault? Was I dreaming about it? Reliving it?
我坐着和凯森博士回顾我的PTSD症状清单。我有关于那次侵犯的记忆吗？我有做关于它的梦吗？重温它吗？
I do feel like I was reliving a little.
我确实感觉我重温了一点。
We finish the checklist and take out the worksheets. I'd done seven the night before. Because I'm doing a crash course in CPT, each session each day covers a week's worth of treatment. It feels like I'm cramming, but Dr. Kaysen tells me she has patients who are still doing worksheets in the waiting room before sessions. That makes me feel a little better.
我们完成了清单并拿出了工作表。我前一天晚上做了七个。因为我在进行CPT的速成课程，每天的每个疗程都涵盖了一周的治疗量。感觉像在死记硬背，但凯森博士告诉我有些病人甚至在疗程前的候诊室里还在做工作表。这让我感觉好了一些。
We pick up with the stuck point we started on yesterday. If I hadn't said hi, he wouldn't have assaulted me.
我们接着昨天开始的卡住点：“如果我没打招呼，他就不会侵犯我。”
Had you interacted with this guy beforehand?
你之前和这个人有过互动吗？
It had been several weeks, probably, of saying hi.
可能已经有几周了，都在打招呼。
OK. And did anything happen on those other days where you said hi?
好的。在那几天你打招呼时发生过什么吗？
No.
没有。
Dr. Kaysen has clearly heard similar stuck points. She pokes holes in my logic until it's obvious that there's another way to see it.
凯森博士显然听过类似的卡住点。她向我的逻辑戳洞，直到显而易见有另一种看待方式。
Could he have assaulted you if you had never said hi?
如果你从没打过招呼，他可能侵犯你吗？
Yes. The likelihood that that was the cause is very small to none.
是的。那种情况是起因的可能性很小甚至为零。
You were a little girl.
你当时还是个小女孩。
Right.
对。
Right? You were a little girl going to school.
对吧？你是个去上学的小女孩。
Right. But still, I wouldn't have said I was a little girl. Like, I felt like I was someone who was able to operate in the world and have conversations and interactions with adults, and have responsibility.
对。但我还是不会说我是个小女孩。就像，我感觉自己是一个能够在世界上运作、与成年人进行对话和互动、并有责任感的人。
I associate the words "little girl" with a kind of unformed, helpless pink thing covered in ruffles. I didn't relate. At 13, I was babysitting. I had crushes and fantasies. I happily went to the movies or thrifting by myself.
我把“小女孩”这个词与某种未成形的、无助的、被褶边覆盖的粉色物体联系起来。我没关联上。13岁时，我做过保姆。我有过暗恋和幻想。我很高兴独自去看电影或去旧货店。
We move on to another one of the stuck points, which was covering something I hadn't thought about for a long time-- what I was wearing on the day of the assault. I wore floral boxers from The Gap and a matching solid colored T-shirt. While doing the worksheets this morning, I realized that some part of me still thought the assault was my fault for wearing men's boxers as shorts. And I tell Dr. Kaysen about this.
我们转向另一个卡住点，它涉及到我很久没想过的事情——侵犯那天我穿了什么。我穿了盖普（The Gap）的花纹平角裤和配套的纯色T恤。今天早上做工作表时，我意识到自己内心某处仍然认为因为我穿男式平角裤当短裤，所以那次侵犯是我的错。我告诉了凯森博士。
I mean, I liked thinking about what I was wearing and trying to wear cute things.
我是说，我喜欢思考我穿什么，尝试穿可爱的衣服。
She assumes that there was some kind of sexiness attached to the outfit for me, but that wasn't it.
她认为这套服装对我来说带有一种性感色彩，但事实并非如此。
Or I didn't wear a sexy outfit.
或者说我没穿性感的衣服。
OK. OK.
好的。好的。
Like, I have never really worn makeup or been good at that kind of thing. It's just like not my-- like, I don't--
比如，我从来没真正化过妆，也不擅长那种东西。这只是不是我的——就像，我不——
Not your thing.
不是你的风格。
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好的。
The outfit wasn't sexy. These were baggy clothes that masked my body. But even as the assault was happening, I remember standing there and thinking it was somehow because of the boxers.
那套衣服不性感。那是遮盖我身体的宽松衣服。但即使在侵犯发生时，我记得站在那里，认为不知怎么就是因为那条平角裤。
I remember being very, like, associating the exact outfit exactly with what was happening. I remember that it was because it was an elastic waistband. That seemed like it was, like, there was more access to me, or that like there was something about the article of clothing and the choice of it that felt--
我记得很清楚，就像把那套衣服与正在发生的事情直接关联起来。我记得那是因为那是弹性腰带。那看起来像是，因为那意味着有更多接触我的途径，或者说是某种关于那件衣服和选择它的理由感觉——
Like that maybe in some way caused it, even if it wasn't the sexy factor.
就像在某种程度上导致了它，即使不是因为性感因素。
Right.
对。
OK. So it might not be the sexy factor, but it might be an access factor.
好的。所以它可能不是性感因素，但可能是可接触性因素。
Or like inappropriate. Like maybe inappropriate clothing.
或者就像是不恰当。就像可能穿着不恰当。
Interesting. OK. All right.
有趣。好的。好吧。
I remember picking out the outfit at The Gap. And I remember putting it in the giveaway pile months later and being asked why I was giving it away since it looked brand new. By the end of the worksheet, my thinking shifts. I articulate my new thought about the boxers-- a more balanced thought, Dr. Kaysen calls it.
我记得在盖普挑选那套衣服。我记得几个月后把它放进捐赠堆，并被问到为什么既然看起来像全新的还要捐掉。工作表结束时，我的想法改变了。我表达了我对平角裤的新看法——凯森博士称之为更平衡的想法。
You know, you came up with this really lovely balanced thought, which is it doesn't matter what you wear. How much do you believe that?
你知道，你想出了这个非常可爱的平衡想法，那就是穿什么并不重要。你相信这个吗？
I believe that. I think it can happen to anyone. I mean, I think it's not-- it has nothing to do with what you're wearing.
我相信。我想这可能发生在任何人身上。我的意思是，我认为这不是——它与你穿什么无关。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm starting to understand Dr. Kaysen's technique with these stuck points. She asks questions so I can arrive at answers myself. My previous belief shifts because I've concluded that it's inaccurate. She's my guide, but I have to come to the conclusion myself.
我开始理解凯森博士运用这些卡住点的技巧了。她提问，这样我就可以自己得出答案。我之前的信念转变了，因为我得出结论它是不准确的。她是我的向导，但我必须自己得出结论。
So when you have that thought-- it doesn't matter what I wear-- what happens to that feeling of shame?
所以当你产生那个想法——我穿什么并不重要——羞耻感发生了什么？
I think it shifts to helplessness in some ways.
我想它在某种程度上转变成了无助感。
Mm, interesting. So if it's what I wear, if I change what I wear, I can be safe.
嗯，有趣。所以如果是因为我穿什么，如果我改变我的穿着，我可以是安全的。
Right.
对。
And if it doesn't matter, then there's nothing I can do.
如果这无关紧要，那么我就无能为力了。
If someone wants to sexually assault you, I think that there's very little you can do.
如果有人想强奸你，我想你几乎无能为力。
At the end of the session, Dr. Kaysen introduces a skill.
疗程结束时，凯森博士引入了一项技能。
All right. So I'm going to teach you something new.
好的。所以我要教你一些新的东西。
OK.
好的。
Finding evidence for whether your stuck point is true. She hands me something called the Challenging Questions Worksheet. The questions are like the ones she asked me during the session, like am I looking at this in an exaggerated way? Am I looking at the whole picture? Am I basing things on facts or feelings? My homework tonight is to do seven more worksheets.
为你的卡住点是否正确寻找证据。她递给我一张叫做“挑战问题工作表”的东西。这些问题就像她在疗程中问我的那些，比如我是否以夸大的方式看待这件事？我是否看到了全貌？我是否基于事实而非感觉？我今晚的家庭作业是再做七个工作表。
All right, I'm going to go make you a bunch of copies of that.
好的，我要去帮你复印一堆那个东西。
OK. And I am going to push Stop.
好的。我要按停止了。
Excellent.
太棒了。
Session four.
第四次疗程。
So first of all, how is your mood?
首先，你心情如何？
You know, I don't know how people live in Seattle.
你知道，我不明白人们怎么在西雅图生活。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
It's very gray and rainy.
太灰暗、太潮湿了。
Yes.
是的。
Like all morning, I really wanted to take a walk.
就像整个早上，我真的想散散步。
I'm not used to the gray, damp fog of Seattle. I understand the moodiness of "Twin Peaks" better and why cardigans were so essential for Kurt Cobain. It doesn't help that the majority of my time is spent alone, holed up making spaghetti and doing homework, piles and piles of homework.
我不习惯西雅图灰暗、潮湿的雾气。我更能理解《双峰》的情绪化，以及为什么开襟羊毛衫对库尔特·柯本来说那么重要。我大部分时间都独自一人，缩在屋里做意大利面和做家庭作业，一大堆一大堆的家庭作业，这并没有什么帮助。
How was the practice?
练习怎么样？
It was harder than the other practice. I think it's also I'm just so used to knowing what therapy is.
比其他的练习更难。我想这也是因为我太习惯于知道心理治疗是什么了。
Is it really different?
它真的不同吗？
It's like, it's super different.
它就像，超级不同。
It is super different.
确实超级不同。
And so I guess I feel like a straight A student in English who's taking a chemistry class. Like, I'm in someone else's clothes.
所以我猜我觉得自己像个英语系的全A学生在修化学课。就像，我穿了别人的衣服。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
And they aren't quite fitting.
而且不太合身。
You're in a different major right now.
你现在换专业了。
Yeah.
是的。
I take out the worksheets, and we loop back to my stuck point about the boxers. I wondered if it would have been harder for him to assault me if I was wearing jeans.
我拿出工作表，回到关于平角裤的卡住点。我想如果我穿的是牛仔裤，他侵犯我是不是会更难？
And from what you know about perpetration, more difficult, does that mean not possible?
根据你对犯罪的了解，更困难，意味着不可能吗？
No, it's still possible.
不，依然有可能。
Yeah. And he had a knife, right?
是的。而且他有把刀，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. OK. And we're going to be working on a skill tomorrow. It looks like you're having some strong feelings as we're working on this one. What's coming up for you right now?
是的。好的。我们明天要研究一项技能。看起来我们在处理这个时你有强烈的感受。你现在想到了什么？
[SNIFFS] [SOBS]
[抽泣]
Stay with it.
坚持住。
I think just thinking about the knife always makes me really emotional.
我想仅仅是想到那把刀总是让我非常情绪化。
Yeah. So I want you to not try and shut the emotions down, OK? Walk me through how it unfolded.
是的。所以我要你不要试图压抑情绪，好吗？告诉我它是如何展开的。
[SIGHS] I was walking to school.
[叹气] 我在走去学校。
Yeah.
是的。
I walked past the alley.
我经过了那条巷子。
I'm not used to speaking out loud about what happened, but I knew that at some point it would come up. It would all come up-- the details, how I felt, what exactly happened in that moment, and what exactly changed.
我不习惯大声说出发生过什么，但我知道迟早会出来的。一切都会出来——细节、我的感受、那一刻到底发生了什么，以及到底改变了什么。
We're nearing the end of our first week together, and I feel like Dr. Kaysen, on purpose or not, has waited until we both felt comfortable. There was trust, the skills of CPT had been discussed, and then this, this story-- the main reason I was here in this room, in this city. It was time for it to come out.
我们在一起的第一周即将结束，我觉得凯森博士，不管是有意还是无意，一直在等我们都感到舒服。信任感建立了，CPT的技能已经讨论过了，然后是这个，这个故事——我出现在这个房间，在这座城市的根本原因。是时候让它说出来了。
And he was kind of in this, like, kind of cove, I guess, behind a bush.
他就在那个，像是一个小海湾里，我想，在一丛灌木后面。
We lived in a very middle class area in West Los Angeles. Our apartment was near two big streets, Santa Monica Boulevard and Beverly Glen. There were office buildings nearby and a big mall with a massive food court.
我们住在西洛杉矶一个非常中产阶级的社区。我们的公寓靠近两条大街，圣莫尼卡大道和贝弗利格伦。附近有办公楼和一个带巨大美食广场的大商场。
My mom's greatest fear in life was that our landlord would sell the duplex, forcing us to leave. It was a place where I knew most of our neighbors. There were always people hanging out in front of their houses. Our across-the-street-neighbors were mechanics with a pitbull named Bumper. It was a tree-lined, sun-kissed, America dream neighborhood.
我母亲一生最大的恐惧是房东会卖掉复式公寓，迫使我们离开。那是一个我知道大多数邻居的地方。总有人在房子的前面闲逛。我们对街的邻居是修理工，养着一只叫Bumper的比特犬。那是一个绿树成荫、阳光亲吻的美国梦社区。
That morning, I walked past an alley between an office building and an apartment building, and the guy was there.
那天早上，我走过办公楼和公寓楼之间的一条巷子，那个人就在那。
And he, like-- like, I smiled or waved, and then he beckoned me over. I didn't know why. And then I walked over.
他，像——像，我微笑了或挥了手，然后他招手让我过去。我不知道为什么。然后我走过去了。
And he held a knife to my side, and then he put his hands down my boxers and felt my vagina. And then I think I said something about, like, protesting. And he said that my father owed him money. And I was like, there's no way that's true.
他用刀抵着我的侧身，然后把手伸进我的平角裤里摸了我的阴道。然后我想我抗议了什么的。他说我父亲欠他的钱。我当时想，那绝不可能。
And then he kept saying, let me just kiss it, and put his mouth on my vagina. And then I scream, but it wasn't a scream. It was just kind of a vocal articulation. It wasn't particularly loud. And then he ran up the alley the other way.
然后他一直说，让我亲一下，把嘴贴在我的阴道上。然后我尖叫，但那不是尖叫。那只是一种声音的表达。不是特别响。然后他向巷子的另一头跑了。
I wish the word vagina didn't feel so clinical. It was more than that. It was like he found a way into my personal sexuality, like a portal into parts of me I hadn't explored or known, because I was so young.
我希望“阴道”这个词听起来不那么临床。它不仅仅是那个。就像他找到了一种进入我个人性行为的方式，像是一个进入我未曾探索或了解的身体部位的门户，因为我太小了。
Eighth grade-- before it happened, I would daydream about having a first kiss. And then after it happened, I thought I'd never be able to. Like, I'd never be able to experience romantic interactions or understand them. Sex, sexual bodies, that shit is hard enough for a 13-year-old.
八年级——在那发生之前，我会幻想拥有初吻。在那之后，我想我永远没法拥有了。就像，我永远无法体验浪漫互动或理解它们。性、性身体，那对13岁的孩子来说已经够难的了。
And so in that moment where he had a knife up to you, what did you think was going to happen? Do you remember?
所以在他用刀抵着你的那一刻，你以为会发生什么？你记得吗？
I have no idea. I didn't know.
我不知道。我不知道。
Yeah. You were just super scared.
是的。你当时超级害怕。
Yep.
是的。
Yeah.
I mean, I think part of the reason that I haven't dealt with a lot of it is like the outcome wasn't-- and I know I've heard this before from other people who have been assaulted, is that the outcome wasn't, like, that bad. I wasn't raped. I wasn't, like, even cut. Like, nothing was physically wrong. Nothing was particularly, like, damaged, I guess, except for psychologically, everything was.
我的意思是，我想我不处理它的大部分原因，是因为结果不是——我知道我从其他被侵犯过的人那里听过这个，就是结果不是，那么糟糕。我没有被强奸。我甚至没有，被割伤。就像，身体上什么也没出问题。没什么特别的，就像，受损，我想，除了在心理上，一切都受损了。
Right.
对。
And so it's, in some ways, I think even harder because I felt like it wasn't so bad. Or I was supposed to think it wasn't so bad.
所以在某种程度上，我觉得这更难，因为我觉得这没那么糟。或者我本应该认为这没那么糟。
So I'm hearing a stuck point around, I shouldn't be distressed, or this wasn't-- there's almost a little bit of a minimizing kind of stuck point.
所以我听到一个关于“我不应该感到痛苦”的卡住点，或者这个不是——几乎有一种淡化性质的卡住点。
Yeah.
是的。
But how would you put it-- what would the belief be around that? The, because I wasn't raped, or because I wasn't cut, I shouldn't have these reactions? I'm not sure exactly what the stuck point is.
但你会怎么说它——围绕它的信念会是什么？因为我没被强奸，或者因为我没被割伤，我不应该有这些反应？我不确定到底卡住点是什么。
I think because it wasn't worse.
我想是因为它没更糟。
Because it wasn't worse, I should be functioning better. I add this to the stuck point log. My experience, by the way, was an outlier in that I was assaulted by a stranger. Sexual assault is usually perpetrated by an acquaintance or family member. Only 7% of juvenile victims who report sexual assault are assaulted by strangers.
因为没更糟，我应该表现得更好。我把它加入卡住点记录。顺便说一句，我的经历是一个特例，我是被陌生人侵犯的。性侵通常是由熟人或家庭成员实施的。只有7%的报告性侵的未成年受害者是被陌生人侵犯的。
At the end of the session, Dr. Kaysen introduces the new skill-- patterns of problematic thinking, which include things like mind reading, and emotional reasoning, and exaggerating, or minimizing. I'm put off by the language. It's oddly formal. I came in thinking CPT was supposed to be accessible, but it's hard to get a handle on. They use real English words, but not in the dictionary definition way. The phrases have a separate CPT meaning.
疗程结束时，凯森博士介绍了新技能——有问题思维的模式，包括读心术、情感推理、夸大或淡化等。我被这些语言弄得有些反感。它异常正式。我进来时以为CPT应该是易于理解的，但很难掌握。他们使用真实的英语单词，但不是字典定义的含义。这些短语有单独的CPT含义。
Do these make sense for the most part for you?
这些对你来说大部分都能理解吗？
Kind of.
算吧。
OK. Where do you have questions?
好的。哪里有疑问？
I guess, what are we doing this for?
我猜，我们做这个是为了什么？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Dr. Kaysen explains that this is part of a process we are in the process of learning, that it will make sense. But I don't see how it's adding up yet. It's just painful and hard.
凯森博士解释说这是我们正在学习的过程的一部分，它会有意义。但我还没看出它有什么加分。这只是痛苦和困难。
All right, but I'm going to make you another copy of the actual patterns form.
好吧，但我会帮你再复印一份实际的模式表格。
OK, cool.
好的，酷。
It's Session five. I've made it to Friday of my first week. It feels like a small victory. I'm thinking of the assault constantly. I'm staying in the gentrified industrial neighborhood of Ballard. It's quiet. There are lots of car repair and tire shops, and warehouses, and expensive microbreweries.
这是第五次疗程。我撑到了第一周的周五。感觉像是一场小小的胜利。我不断地想到那次侵犯。我住在巴拉德那个中产阶级化的工业社区。那里很安静。有很多汽车修理和轮胎店，还有仓库和昂贵的微型啤酒厂。
Crossing the street, I'm reminded of the alley. Locking the doors at night to the Airbnb, I worry about security. I don't know anyone around me, and I feel alone. I don't want to take risks. I don't want to explore Seattle. I won't go for a run.
穿过马路时，我想起了那条巷子。晚上锁上爱彼迎的门时，我担心安全问题。我不认识周围的任何人，感到孤独。我不想冒险。我不想去探索西雅图。我不会去跑步。
Taking too many risks or doing things that could cause you harm.
冒太多险或者做可能导致伤害的事。
Zero.
零。
OK. Being super alert or watchful or on guard.
好的。超级警觉、戒备或防卫。
Two.
二。
OK.
好的。
Today, after the PTSD checklist, Dr. Kaysen reveals the worksheet that all the worksheets were leading up to this whole time. It has many boxes, and tables, and questions, 26 in all. It's the mother of all worksheets. It includes all the things I've learned on the worksheets til now. It's intimidating and complicated, but Dr. Kaysen reminds me that I know how to do each step. She says now that I have all the skills I need to do CPT, the therapy will shift.
今天，在PTSD检查清单之后，凯森博士揭示了所有工作表一直导向的那张工作表。它有许多格子、表格和问题，总共26个。它是所有工作表的“母亲”。它包含了迄今为止我在工作表上学到的所有东西。这很令人生畏且复杂，但凯森博士提醒我，我知道如何做每一步。她说现在我有做CPT所需的所有技能，治疗将发生转变。
But what we're going to be doing from this session on out is we're going to start working with different themes. The first one we're going to focus in on is around safety.
但从这次疗程开始，我们将开始研究不同的主题。我们要关注的第一个主题是关于安全。
OK.
好的。
OK? So how this event may have affected your ideas about safety.
好吗？所以这个事件是如何影响你关于安全的想法的。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
We practice a couple stuck points on the big mama worksheet. One of them is about how I'm feeling uncomfortable in Seattle. I mention that the Dodgers are playing in the World Series, and I'm hesitant to walk the few blocks to the bar at the end of my street. But I really want to watch the game.
我们在“大妈”工作表上练习了几个卡住点。其中一个关于我在西雅图感到不舒服。我提到道奇队正在打世界大赛，我犹豫要不要走几条街到我街尾的酒吧去。但我真的很想看比赛。
Dr. Kaysen says that I should consider trying to go to the bar to watch the game, that it's actually not risky behavior. She's not a big baseball fan, so I almost feel like the assignment is for both of us.
凯森博士说我应该考虑去酒吧看比赛，其实那不是冒险行为。她不是棒球迷，所以我几乎觉得这个任务是给我们俩布置的。
You know, I'm going to ask you on Monday whether you saw the game.
你知道，周一我会问你有没有看比赛。
Went to it. [LAUGHS]
去看了。[笑]
Yes. Yes. OK. All right. So in terms of--
是的。是的。好的。所以关于——
And I'll ask you if you know what the score was.
而且我会问你比分是多少。
Oh. Oh. [LAUGHS] Hmm.
哦。哦。[笑] 嗯。
There are several games, actually.
其实有好几场比赛。
But I will have to actually-- I hate to tell you this, but I'm really treatment resistant.
但我不得不实际上——我讨厌告诉你这一点，但我真的很“治疗抗拒”。
[LAUGHS] This sounds like a stuck point.
[笑] 这听起来像是一个卡住点。
It could be a stuck point.
这可能是一个卡住点。
We could get through the baseball stuck point.
我们可以克服棒球卡住点。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
We can work together on this.
我们可以一起解决这个问题。
Absolutely. We'll set it as a long-term treatment goal.
当然。我们将把它设为长期治疗目标。
Yeah.
是的。
All right. So in terms of resolutions--
好的。所以关于决议——
As hard as this week has been, it helps that I trust Dr. Kaysen. She's a good guide.
尽管这一周很难，但信任凯森博士对我有所帮助。她是位好向导。
Jaime Lowe. Coming up, if you learn something important about yourself from a worksheet, is it OK to feel resentful that you learned it from a worksheet? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
杰米·洛。接下来，如果你从工作表中了解到了关于自己的重要信息，感到愤愤不平是因为你是从工作表中了解到的，这可以吗？一会儿回来，芝加哥公共广播，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Ten Sessions. What can you do with trauma from long ago that's never healed? If you're just tuning in, writer Jaime Lowe heard about a kind of therapy called CPT, Cognitive Processing Therapy, that helps people deal with unhealed trauma from sexual assault or combat PTSD, incredibly, in just 10 or 12 sessions. And she decided to try it herself. We pick up halfway through the therapy.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“十次疗程”。对于从未愈合的很久以前的创伤，你能做什么？如果你刚调频收听，作家杰米·洛听说了一种叫CPT（认知处理疗法）的疗法，能帮助人们解决性侵或战斗PTSD带来的未愈合创伤，令人难以置信的是，只需10或12次疗程。她决定亲自尝试。我们在治疗进行到一半时继续。
Session six.
第六次疗程。
All right, so in general, since I last saw you on Friday, how has your mood been?
好的，那么总体来说，自周五上次见你以来，心情如何？
It's Monday, and I've self-cared my way through the weekend, which is another way to say that I went to a handful of vintage clothing stores. I bought a poncho the colors of Mardi Gras. I did not buy the T-shirt that said "Rain, and Coffee, and Salmon, and Weed." The Dodgers lost the series, but I went to the bar to watch the game, and it was fine. It was actually nice.
今天是周一，我通过周末的“自我关怀”撑过来了，换句话说，我逛了几家古着店。我买了一件马尔迪格拉斯色彩的披风。我没有买那件印着“雨、咖啡、鲑鱼和大麻”的T恤。道奇队输掉了系列赛，但我还是去酒吧看了比赛，情况还可以。其实还挺不错的。
All right. So do you want to check levels? And then we will delve in.
好的。你想检查音频电平吗？然后我们深入探讨。
Yeah. Why don't you speak a tiny bit?
好的。你为什么不稍微说几句？
We check the audio levels. I still have no idea if I'm doing it right. I tell myself, worst case scenario, I won't be able to share the most traumatic moments of my life with millions of people. And that seems like an OK outcome.
我们检查音频电平。我仍然不知道我做得对不对。我告诉自己，最坏的情况是，我没法与数百万人分享我生命中最具创伤性的时刻。那似乎是一个可以接受的结果。
I take out the big mama worksheets I did over the weekend. Each sheet took a lot longer than I expected. Dr. Kaysen picks out a worksheet with the stuck point, I can't protect myself.
我拿出周末做的“大妈”工作表。每一张表花费的时间都比我预期的要长。凯森博士挑选了一张写有“我无法保护自己”这个卡住点的工作表。
OK, I can't protect myself. Oh, good. This is a great one to do, also, with you going out to the bar, too.
好的，“我无法保护自己”。哦，好。这也是一个很好的练习，尤其是在你去酒吧之后。
Yeah.
是的。
Like really relevant.
真的很相关。
Dr. Kaysen pauses. It seems like she's seeing a stuck point in the stuck point, which happens a lot-- Russian dolls of stuck points.
凯森博士停顿了一下。看起来她在卡住点中又看到了一个卡住点，这种情况经常发生——像俄罗斯套娃一样的卡住点。
Let me ask you a question also. There's another piece here. Are you different now than you were then?
让我问你一个问题。这儿还有一部分。你现在和当时不同了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
How so?
怎么不同？
I'm older. I know more. I've learned from that experience.
我长大了。我知道得更多。我从那个经历中学到了东西。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
This reminds me of that song Into the Woods, the musical.
这让我想起了那首音乐剧《走进森林》里的歌。
Ah.
啊。
The Little Red Riding Hood song, which is basically all about sexual trauma.
小红帽那首歌，基本上全是关于性创伤的。
There's a song from Stephen Sondheim's musical, Into the Woods, that I used to listen to over and over after the attack. The wolf beckons Little Red Riding Hood. She strays from the path, and then she sings, "He drew me close and he swallowed me down, down a dark slimy path where life's secrets that I never want to know and when everything familiar seemed to disappear forever." I mean, those lyrics described how I felt in the aftermath of the assault to a tee, that everything familiar seemed to disappear forever.
史蒂芬·桑德海姆的音乐剧《走进森林》里有一首歌，那次袭击后我曾反复听。大狼引诱小红帽。她偏离了路径，然后唱道：“他把我拉近，把我吞了下去，沿着一条黑暗、黏糊糊的路径，那里有我永远不想知道的生活秘密，当所有熟悉的事物似乎永远消失了。”我的意思是，这些歌词精准地描述了那次侵犯后我的感受，所有熟悉的一切似乎都永远消失了。
Dr. Kaysen and I walk through the worksheet, step by step, through all the prompts and questions CPT relies on-- whether there's evidence for my stuck point, whether I'm making an all or nothing statement, whether I'm jumping to conclusions, what I'm leaving out. I realize that I still feel angry with myself for freezing, that I didn't scream sooner, hit him, run, or defend myself. Dr. Kaysen reminds me that he had a knife.
凯森博士和我一步步地走过工作表，通过CPT所依赖的所有提示和问题——是否存在支持我卡住点的证据，我是否在做非黑即白的陈述，我是否在匆忙下结论，我遗漏了什么。我意识到我仍然对自己因为僵住而感到愤怒，没能早点尖叫、打他、逃跑或自我防御。凯森博士提醒我他有刀。
If somebody's got a weapon, sometimes freezing is the best response in that moment.
如果有人有武器，有时僵住是那一刻最好的反应。
Or the only response. We continue going through it. And eventually, I reach a more balanced thought.
或者是唯一的反应。我们继续进行下去。最终，我得出了一个更平衡的想法。
Good. I did what I could to protect myself from physical harm. Absolutely. That's beautiful that you came up with that.
好。我尽我所能保护自己免受身体伤害。绝对。你能得出这个结论太棒了。
The big mama worksheets ask for percentages related to how much you feel things and to how much you believe certain thoughts. At the beginning of this worksheet, I believed I can't protect myself 70%. By the end, I'm in a different place.
“大妈”工作表要求填入与你的感受强度和对某些想法的信任度相关的百分比。在这张工作表开始时，我以70%的程度相信“我无法保护自己”。到最后，我处于一个不同的位置。
And so you've managed to get that from 70% to 20%. That's some really nice movement around that.
所以你成功地将它从70%降到了20%。围绕这一点有非常好的进展。
Yeah. I don't fully understand the percentages, but I did feel better after working through it.
是的。我不完全理解这些百分比，但在处理完之后我确实感觉好多了。
Nice. And fear came down, anger came down, and frustration came down. Nice. That's lovely. And you've also got some other balanced thoughts in here, too, like, I can protect myself most of the time.
好。恐惧降下来了，愤怒降下来了，挫败感也降下来了。好。太棒了。你在这里还有其他一些平衡的想法，比如，“我大部分时间都能保护自己。”
Yeah.
是的。
You can think about how does that feel, versus I can't protect myself at all. Right. Beautiful job with that.
你可以考虑一下那是什么感觉，对比“我根本无法保护自己”。对。做得漂亮。
Suddenly, I'm getting the worksheets. They're still difficult, because thinking is difficult. But that night, I find that doing them is calming and clear. The next day, in session seven, I tell Dr. Kaysen that there's something about the writing that's really key.
突然间，我理解这些工作表了。它们依然困难，因为思考是困难的。但那天晚上，我发现做这些练习让我感到冷静且清晰。第二天，在第七次疗程中，我告诉凯森博士，关于写作的某件事真的很关键。
And so when I'm writing it down, I'm just seeing that even just subtle shifts are really different when you write it.
所以当我写下它时，我发现即使只是微妙的转变，当你写下来时也真的不同。
That's right.
没错。
I can see the beginning point. And then I see the end, and I'm just like, ah. It's like you're forehead-slapping. You're just like, oh, yeah, that starting point was really off, like, that's not a rational way to think.
我可以看到起始点。然后我看到了终点，我只是想，啊。这就像你额头被猛击一下。你只是想，噢，对了，那个起点真的很偏离，就像，那不是一种理性的思考方式。
Right. But I love what I'm hearing you say is, also, you're really seeing some cognitive shifts with doing these. So it's hard work, but you're also seeing some payout.
对。但我喜欢听到你所说的，你确实通过这些练习看到了认知的转变。这很辛苦，但你也看到了回报。
Yeah. I think I'm also a little resentful that it's just coming from a worksheet.
是的。我也对这仅仅源于一张工作表感到有点愤愤不平。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I'm serious. Like, there's something like--
我是认真的。就像，有什么——
Why?
为什么？
Because it's like-- I can't describe it, but it's sort of like-- OK, I think I can describe it. I think that in talk therapy or traditional analysis, it's so individualized, it's so cocooned, it's so specified to your relationship with one person in that space and that time. And it's very much like a special thing.
因为就像——我说不上来，但它有点像——好的，我想我能描述它。我觉得在谈话疗法或传统的分析中，它非常个性化，非常像茧一样，非常特定于你在那个空间和那个时间与一个人的关系。这非常像一件特别的事情。
Whereas a worksheet, it's an equation. And so it's more generic, which actually makes it way better in a lot of ways.
然而工作表，它是一个公式。所以它在许多方面其实更通用，这使它在很多方面变得更好。
But also hard because it feels less special.
但也很难，因为它感觉没那么特别。
Right, but also kind of like not this precious thing. You're special, and your problems are special.
对，但也确实不像是那种珍贵的东西。你是特别的，你的问题也是特别的。
Huh, that's interesting.
嗯，真有趣。
I like that the goal of CPT is to have the tools to be your own therapist. Several CPT experts told me their role as clinicians was to put themselves out of business. I'm not sure that's true of talk therapy-- for me, anyway.
我喜欢CPT的目标是拥有成为自己心理治疗师的工具。几位CPT专家告诉我，他们作为临床医生的角色就是让自己“失业”。我不确定谈话疗法也是这样——至少对我来说不是。
I don't set an end goal. With CPT, I have. I know exactly what I want to work on, and I'm drilling down on that one thing. I'm dealing with the after effects of sexual assault. And I have a list of stuck points to show for it-- 31 different sentences written sloppily on a piece of paper, like a list of groceries. Dr. Kaysen asks me if I've crossed any off.
我没有设定结束目标。而通过CPT，我有了。我知道我确切地想解决什么，我正在钻研那一件事。我正在处理性侵后的余波。我有一份卡住点列表作为证明——31个潦草写在纸上的不同句子，就像一张杂货清单。凯森博士问我是否划掉了几个。
I crossed off a bunch that I just didn't think were stuck points in the first place. And then I crossed off some that I felt like we worked through.
我划掉了一堆我觉得根本不是卡住点的内容。然后我划掉了一些我觉得我们已经解决的。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
If I hadn't said hi, he wouldn't have assaulted me-- done with that. I can't trust my judgment-- crossed off. Because it wasn't worse, I should be functioning better-- gone. I've been working so hard to learn the process of CPT that I didn't realize how much I'd resolved along the way.
“如果我没打招呼，他就不会侵犯我”——解决了。“我无法相信自己的判断”——划掉了。“因为没更糟，我应该表现得更好”——没了。我一直努力在学习CPT的过程，没意识到我在这一路上解决了这么多。
I leave the session feeling a sense of accomplishment. I love making lists. I love crossing things off my lists. This is starting to feel satisfying.
我带着成就感离开了疗程。我喜欢列清单。我喜欢把东西从清单上划掉。这开始让我感到满足了。
You check my levels, and I'll check yours--
你检查我的电平，我检查你的——
And then you can check my levels.
然后你可以检查我的电平。
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好的。
It's session eight, and Dr. Kaysen and I are making levels jokes. I'll check the level of her volume, and she'll check the levels of my PTSD symptoms.
这是第八次疗程了，凯森博士和我正在开“电平”玩笑。我检查她的音量电平，她检查我的PTSD症状电平。
So since yesterday, how much have you been distressed by repeated disturbing and unwanted memories of the traumatic event?
所以从昨天以来，你因反复出现创伤事件令人不安和不想要的记忆而感到痛苦的程度如何？
Two-- eh, one.
二——呃，一。
OK.
好的。
Probably one.
可能是一。
Dr. Kaysen and I are starting to get into a nice, comfortable rhythm. And of course, there's only three sessions left, including this one.
凯森博士和我开始进入一种舒适的节奏。当然，包括这次在内，只剩下三次疗程了。
It's Halloween, and she's got on themed earrings and spider web tights. In another setting, I might find this kind of ridiculous, but I know her enough to know it's genuine and wonderful. And I feel sad I'm not dressed up, too.
今天是万圣节，她戴着主题耳环，穿着蜘蛛网连裤袜。在另一个场合，我可能会觉得这很荒谬，但我足够了解她，知道这是真诚且美妙的。我觉得我也没打扮感到难过。
We go through my big mama worksheets. Just as Dr. Kaysen said we would, we've been using the big worksheets to explore big themes. We've gone through safety and esteem. Today is control. And one of my stuck points is, when I'm not in control, bad things will happen, which I believe 80%.
我们过了一遍“大妈”工作表。就像凯森博士所说的，我们一直在用大工作表探索大主题。我们已经走过了安全和自尊。今天是控制。我的卡住点之一是“当我失去控制时，坏事就会发生”，我对此有80%的相信。
So what evidence do you have that, if you are not in control, bad things will happen?
那么你有什么证据表明，如果你没有控制，坏事就会发生？
Bad things have happened when I haven't been in control.
坏事发生时我都没有控制。
OK. So you could say things in the past.
好的。所以你可以说过去发生的事件。
OK.
好的。
OK? So I'm assuming like the sexual assault, events that happen when you are manic. OK. OK.
好吗？所以我假设是像那次性侵，在你处于躁狂状态时发生的事件。好的。好的。
When Dr. Kaysen asks about mania, I pause, just sit there for a while. Then I nod without saying anything. Control is a big thing for me. It's a big thing in mania. You're not in control, but you think you are. Dr. Kaysen and I keep going through this sheet. My statement, when I'm not in control, bad things will happen-- is there evidence it might not be true?
当凯森博士问到躁狂症时，我停顿了一下，在那儿坐了很久。然后我没说话，点了点头。控制对我来说是个大问题。在躁狂症中这更是一个大问题。你没有控制，但你认为你有。凯森博士和我继续看那张表。我的陈述，“当我失去控制时，坏事就会发生”——有证据表明这可能不是真的吗？
So bad things can happen when--
所以坏事发生时——
I'm in control.
我有控制。
When you are in control-- yeah, absolutely. And have you ever been out of control and not had something bad happen?
当你确实有控制时——对，绝对。而且你有没有过失去控制却没发生坏事的时候？
Yeah.
有。
We go over my answers to each of the little boxes on the worksheet. By the end, I have a new thought. Giving up control does not always mean bad things will happen. Dr. Kaysen asks, what feelings come up when I'm thinking about giving up control? Fear is the first one. And then--
我们过了一遍我对工作表中每个小格子的回答。到最后，我有了个新想法。“放弃控制并不总是意味着坏事会发生。”凯森博士问，当我想到放弃控制时，产生了什么感觉？恐惧是第一个。然后——
There's definitely a lot of guilt and shame.
确实有很多罪恶感和羞耻感。
Yeah, so I--
是的，所以我觉得——
I've really come around to the shame concept.
我真的开始接受“羞耻”这个概念了。
Yeah, you've really been--
是的，你确实一直在——
I'm really embracing it.
我真的在拥抱它。
Yeah, you have. That's true. That is true.
是的，你做到了。那确实是真的。那确实是真的。
We're joking, but there's something there. I'm realizing that, for me, shame is related to mental illness. After mania, it's hard not to want to be buried for a decade, until everyone forgets that you tried to start a hippie cult in a tutu covered in glitter and war paint.
我们在开玩笑，但这里面确实有东西。我意识到，对我来说，羞耻感与精神疾病有关。在躁狂发作后，很难不想要隐姓埋名十年，直到每个人都忘记了你试图在一个穿着带亮片的芭蕾舞裙、涂着战彩的嬉皮教派中开场。
Today, at the end of the session, my homework is a little different.
今天，疗程结束时，我的作业有点不同。
And then I want you to practice giving one compliment and receiving one compliment.
然后我想要你练习给别人一个恭维，并接受一个恭维。
I don't really speak to people that much.
我不怎么和别人说话。
Yeah, now I know. So it would mean you'd have to speak to people.
是的，现在我知道了。所以这意味着你必须和人说话。
Give one compliment, and--
给一个恭维，和——
And receive one compliment.
接受一个恭维。
How do I make someone compliment me?
我怎么让别人恭维我？
So that's tough, because you're in a strange city.
所以这很难，因为你在一个陌生的城市。
Yeah.
是的。
So what it's going to mean is a couple of things. Either you're going to need to listen for compliments you're getting naturally without filtering them.
所以这意味着几件事。要么你需要倾听你自然得到的恭维而不过滤它们。
OK.
好的。
Or sometimes if you're interacting with people, then you may be more likely to get compliments.
或者有时如果你和别人互动，那么你更有可能得到恭维。
This is the point of the exercise. Dr. Kaysen is preparing me for life post-treatment by encouraging me to interact with people. She explains that social isolation often follows PTSD.
这就是练习的目的。凯森博士鼓励我与人互动，为治疗后的生活做准备。她解释说PTSD之后经常会伴随社会孤立。
Session nine.
第九次疗程。
All right. Well, let's dig in to how the practice went.
好的。那么，让我们来探讨一下练习进展如何。
OK.
好的。
Before we go into worksheets, how did the giving and receiving compliments go?
在进入工作表之前，给别人恭维和接受恭维怎么样了？
Yesterday when Dr. Kaysen gave me the compliment assignment, it seemed difficult and silly. It felt like I entered Mr. Roger's land. And even though I know he was a good soul, I was always a Muppets Show person.
昨天凯森博士给我布置恭维作业时，它看起来很难也很傻。感觉像我进入了罗杰斯先生的邻里。尽管我知道他是个好人，但我一直是芝麻街木偶秀的粉丝。
I wasn't entirely sure how to conjure up compliments. As I anticipated, giving compliments was pretty easy. I told Dr. Kaysen that I told my Airbnb guy I liked his record collection and his illustrations.
我不完全确定怎么变出恭维。正如我预料的，给别人恭维相当容易。我告诉凯森博士，我告诉我的爱彼迎房东我喜欢他的唱片收藏和插画。
Yeah, nice. Did you get any compliments?
是的，好。你得到恭维了吗？
I did. It was really funny, actually.
得到了。其实真的很有趣。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I got a very-- a really, really, really big compliment, to me.
我得到了一个——对我来说真的、真的、真的很大的恭维。
Yeah.
是的。
I pause. I'm choking up.
我停顿了一下。我哽咽了。
[SNIFFS] Someone wrote me an email [SNIFFS] just about my book.
[抽泣] 有人给我写了一封邮件[抽泣]，关于我的书。
About my book, Mental, the memoir I wrote about being bipolar. The email was from a young woman who is also bipolar.
关于我的书，《Mental》，那本我写的关于躁郁症的回忆录。邮件来自一个同样患有躁郁症的年轻女性。
She had to leave college, and go home, and kind of really shift her plans. And she said that she really felt like the story that I told was something that she had never read, but could really relate to. It was a really big compliment.
她不得不休学，回家，真的大幅度调整了她的计划。她说她真的觉得我讲的故事是她从未读过，但真的能产生共鸣的。那是一个非常大的恭维。
That's powerful.
这很有力量。
We'd been talking in a previous session about my feelings of being a failure, of not doing well at my work. Dr. Kaysen wants me to remember this email.
我们在之前的疗程中讨论过我关于“失败者”的感觉，关于在工作中做得不好。凯森博士希望我记住这封邮件。
I can try and remember it. [LAUGHS] It's hard. It's really hard for me to remember the positive responses, like, to anything.
我可以试着记住它。[笑] 这很难。对我来说，记住积极的回应真的很难，就像，任何东西的积极回应。
Yep. And so this is one for you to practice, right? So we're starting to move into life skills, right?
是的。所以这是你需要练习的一个，对吧？所以我们开始进入生活技能了，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
This is one that's going to be a life skill for you. What am I leaving out? That's been a really helpful question for you. Right? It forces you to get out of that negative space and look for things that don't fit with the stuck point.
这将是一个给你的生活技能。“我遗漏了什么？”这对你来说一直是一个非常有帮助的问题。对吧？它强迫你跳出那个消极的空间，去寻找那些不符合卡住点的事物。
This is the next to last session, and I can feel we're coming to the end. The way Dr. Kaysen is talking and the way I'm feeling, it just feels close to over. And then my last homework assignment is revealed.
这是倒数第二次疗程了，我能感觉到我们快要结束了。凯森博士说话的方式和我感觉的方式，感觉快要结束了。然后我的最后家庭作业揭晓了。
I want you to write at least one page on what you think, now, about why the traumatic event occurred.
我想要你写至少一页关于你现在怎么看待为什么那个创伤事件发生了。
OK.
好的。
It makes sense. If one purpose of this therapy is to change the story you're telling yourself, it would be a good gauge to write a before and after, to see how the narrative shifts-- the perfect book ends.
这说得通。如果这种疗法的目的之一是改变你告诉自己的故事，那么写一份“之前”和“之后”来查看叙事是如何转变的将是一个很好的衡量标准——完美的结尾。
Session ten.
第十次疗程。
How was it writing the second impact statement?
写第二份“影响陈述”感觉如何？
It was good. It felt like it was less fraught.
挺好的。感觉少了很多焦虑。
It's the day of my last session, and it's like Seattle knows it. This morning, I rode the ferry and saw a double rainbow. I walked around Bainbridge Island with a friend and saw sun, real sun through trees and abandoned mills, sun shining against the sound, and against graffiti, and against soaring seagulls, sun that reflected on the sign for Bernie's Automotive Service that read, "Welcome to the team, Charlie." It all looked shining and miraculous. I could feel the excitement of being done. And the Pacific Northwest felt it with me.
这是我最后一次疗程的那天，就像西雅图知道一样。今天早上，我乘轮渡看到了双彩虹。我和一个朋友在贝恩布里奇岛散步，看到了太阳，真正的阳光穿过树林和废弃的磨坊，阳光照在海峡上，照在涂鸦上，照在翱翔的海鸥上，阳光反射在伯尼汽车服务公司的招牌上，写着“欢迎加入团队，查理”。这一切看起来光芒万丈、奇迹般。我能感受到结束的兴奋。太平洋西北地区也和我一起感受到了。
Writing the second impact statement was easier than writing the first one. I didn't feel pent up emotions spilling over. I didn't feel out of control.
写第二份影响陈述比第一份容易得多。我没感到压抑的情绪溢出。我没感到失去控制。
Nice. So I'm going to have you read it to me.
好。我要你读给我听。
OK.
好的。
OK?
好吗？
The attack happened because-- who knows why it happened? I don't know why he molested me. I don't know what motivated him. I know that it didn't happen because I was there, or wearing boxers, or friendly, or willing it upon myself. I was young and walking to school, not looking for a sexual assault. That's pretty improbable. Why would anyone look for that?
那次袭击发生是因为——谁知道为什么发生？我不知道他为什么猥亵我。我不知道是什么动机驱使他。我知道那不是因为我在那儿，或穿着平角裤，或表现友好，或故意招惹。我那时很小，走在去学校的路上，没在寻找性侵。那太不可能了。谁会寻找那种事？
I think it happened because-- I just really can't explain why. He was in control. He had a knife. I did everything I could to protect myself and to get away. My feelings after it happened were natural. My response was as good as it could be. Good is the wrong word, but I think I did OK, considering all of the circumstances.
我想它发生是因为——我实在无法解释为什么。他控制了局面。他有把刀。我尽我所能保护自己并逃脱。我发生后的感觉是自然的。我的反应尽可能好了。好这个词用得不对，但我想我做得还可以，考虑到所有的环境。
I keep going. And when I get to the end, Dr. Kaysen reads back what I wrote after our first session, my original impact statement.
我继续读。当我读完时，凯森博士读回了我们在第一次疗程后写的东西，我最初的影响陈述。
So let me read back to you what you wrote the first time.
让我读回你第一次写的东西。
OK.
好的。
I was young, 13, and I don't think I knew much about actual human nature-- friendliness, strangers. It's funny to think that I was not cautious about the very thing kids are always warned of-- strangers. I walked to my bus stop alone every morning.
“我当时很小，13岁，我觉得我不了解人性——友善，陌生人。有趣的是，我竟然没对孩子们常被叮嘱要防范的东西——陌生人——保持警惕。我每天早上独自走去巴士站。”
Dr. Kaysen keeps reading, and I can hear how my story has changed.
凯森博士继续读，我能听出我的故事发生了怎样的变化。
So what changes do you hear?
你听到了什么变化？
Well, I think there's a huge shift of focus. Now, it feels like there's just a different way of seeing it.
嗯，我想关注点发生了巨大的转变。现在，感觉只是有一种不同的看待方式。
Right.
对。
Like, that attack just doesn't feel as potent, I think.
就像，那次袭击感觉没那么强大了，我想。
Yep. Yep. That's what I heard, too. And also, really an acceptance that you may never know-- in fact, you probably will never know-- exactly why it happened. But you can be really confident that it didn't have anything to do with you.
对。对。我也听到了。而且，真的接受了你可能永远不会知道——事实上，你可能永远不会知道——它到底为什么发生。但你可以非常自信它与你无关。
Right. Which is something that I do think I intellectually understood, but it wasn't something I accepted, I don't think.
对。这是我理性上确实理解的东西，但我觉得这不是我接受的东西。
Right.
对。
And I think that in the difference between the first statement to the last, there was acceptance in that.
而且我认为在第一份陈述到最后一份陈述之间，有一种接受感。
Acceptance that it wasn't me, that it wasn't my fault. Dr. Kaysen hands me a print-out of the PTSD check-ins that we did at the beginning of each session. By the end, my number has dropped from the initial total by about 12 points. She says 10 points indicates meaningful change. The number doesn't mean that much to me, but I do feel better. I know that. She wonders how I feel about the therapy, overall.
接受它不是我，不是我的错。凯森博士递给我一份我们在每次疗程开始时做的PTSD检查清单的打印件。到最后，我的分数比最初的总分下降了约12点。她说10点表示有意义的转变。这个数字对我来说意义不大，但我确实感觉好多了。我知道。她想知道我总体上对这种治疗感觉如何。
What did you notice in the process? What was helpful for you? What was not helpful? How have you seen shifts?
你在过程中注意到了什么？什么对你有帮助？什么没有帮助？你是怎么看到转变的？
Well, I've definitely seen-- I mean, I think working through all of this stuff about the assault was incredibly helpful, because I felt like there was a lot of unresolved assumptions that I didn't really even recognize were there. And that it was, frankly, kind of a relief to not really have that there as much. Like it just kind of feels better.
嗯，我确实看到了——我的意思是，我觉得处理所有这些关于侵犯的事情非常有帮助，因为我觉得有很多我甚至都没意识到存在的未解决的假设。说实话，没有那么多那种假设作为负担，这真是一种解脱。就像，感觉好多了。
The process of CPT surprised me. Its effectiveness surprised me. I could see in just those two statements how the ten sessions in between shifted my thinking. This is like ninja therapy. They distract you with the weird language, and then progress creeps up on you from behind. As always, Dr. Kaysen is huggable, gracious, warm. I'm going to miss her. I'm sad to leave, even though I know it's time, and I know I can.
CPT的过程让我感到惊讶。它的有效性让我感到惊讶。我从那两份陈述中看到了中间十次疗程是如何转变我的想法的。这就像忍者治疗。他们用古怪的语言分散你的注意力，然后进步从后面悄悄地靠近你。一如既往，凯森博士是那样可拥抱、优雅、温暖。我会想念她的。我很难过要离开，尽管我知道是时候了，我知道我可以。
Is that it?
就这些吗？
That's it.
就这些。
That's the end?
这就结束了？
The end.
结束。
All right.
好的。
It's been 10 months since I did CPT. I still have my folder stuffed with more than 100 worksheets. The spine is reinforced with neon orange duct tape, because the folder is falling apart, but I'm not. I feel like I did, in fact, get something I wanted out of this, more than what I expected.
自从我做CPT已经过去10个月了。我的文件夹里依然塞满了100多份工作表。书脊用霓虹橙色胶带加固过，因为文件夹快散架了，但我没有。我觉得我确实从这儿得到了我想要的，比预期的还要多。
I don't feel as hopeless and incapacitated when I hear about other assaults. The news doesn't dictate my emotional state in the same way. When Jeffrey Epstein was found dead, I was angry on behalf of his victims. I shouted a few expletives and threw my phone on the ground, but I could still function. And really, that's a very rational reaction.
当我听到其他侵犯事件时，我没感到那么绝望和无能为力。新闻不会以同样的方式支配我的情绪状态。当杰弗里·爱泼斯坦被发现死亡时，我为他的受害者感到愤怒。我喊了几句脏话并把手机扔在地上，但我依然能正常工作。真的，那是一个非常理性的反应。
Before CPT, I had a lot of anxiety and overwhelming feelings. I was experiencing PTSD symptoms, which I didn't even realize. I had my suspicions that these intense emotions were related to the assault, but it was never named for me. Now, my symptoms are mostly gone. And when problems come up, I can work them through in my head, or I pull out a blank worksheet.
CPT之前，我有很多焦虑和难以承受的情绪。我经历了PTSD症状，而我甚至没意识到。我怀疑这些强烈的情绪与侵犯有关，但从未有人为我命名。现在，我的症状基本消失了。当问题出现时，我可以在脑子里梳理它们，或者我拿出一张空白工作表。
There's a surge of women seeking help right now. A National Sexual Assault hotline saw a 200% increase over normal volume after the Kavanaugh hearing. There was a 20% increase in calls after the R. Kelly doc aired. After the sentencing hearing of Larry Nassar, calls to the same hotline increased by 46%. Of course, so many survivors of sexual assault don't get any treatment at all-- not talk therapy, not CPT, nothing.
现在有大量女性寻求帮助。卡瓦诺听证会后，全美性侵热线的呼叫量比正常水平增加了200%。R·凯利纪录片播出后，呼叫量增加了20%。拉里·纳萨尔量刑听证会后，打给同一条热线的呼叫增加了46%。当然，太多的性侵幸存者根本得不到任何治疗——没有谈话疗法，没有CPT，什么都没有。
When I started CPT, it was hard to say I'd been sexually assaulted out loud. I think I carried a lot of shame-- the word I was most offended by. But now I can say it, and I can say it without crying. I was sexually assaulted when I was 13.
当我开始做CPT时，很难大声说出我遭到过性侵。我想我背负了太多羞耻感——那个我最反感的词。但现在我能说出来，而且说的时候不会流泪。我在13岁时遭到过性侵。
Jaime Lowe, she's the author of a memoir called Mental. In the month since she saw Dr. Debra Kaysen, Dr. Kaysen has moved from the University of Washington to Stanford.
杰米·洛，她是回忆录《Mental》的作者。在见到黛布拉·凯森博士后的一个月里，凯森博士从华盛顿大学调到了斯坦福大学。
[MUSIC - MARY J. BLIGE, "THERAPY"]
[音乐 - 玛丽·布莱姬，《Therapy》]
Our program was produced today by Susan Burton. People who put together today's show includes Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Damien Grave, Michelle Harris, Jessica Lussenhopp, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Svetala, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们今天的节目由苏珊·伯顿制作。参与今天节目录制的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔娜·贝克、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹杰菲尔德、尼尔·德鲁明、达米安·格雷夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、杰西卡·卢森霍普、斯托·纳尔逊、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、艾丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的总编辑是吴黛安。执行编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。
Special thanks to Emily Dworkin, Patricia Resick, Henry Schwartz, and Shawn Bishop. Original music for today's show by Daniel Hart. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 680 episodes for absolutely free. Also there's videos and tons of other stuff there, too. Or get our app, which has all that stuff and also lets you download as many episodes as you want. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢艾米丽·德沃金、帕特里夏·雷西克、亨利·施瓦茨和肖恩·毕晓普。今天节目的原创音乐由丹尼尔·哈特制作。访问我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，你可以免费在线收听我们超过680集的存档。那里还有视频和大量其他内容。或者获取我们的应用程序，它拥有所有这些内容，并允许你随心所欲地下载任意集数。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He took some ayahuasca before painting his own apartment-- not a good idea. He was getting the primer ready, and he said one of the walls started talking to him that said--
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给各公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他在粉刷自己的公寓前吸食了死藤水——这不是个好主意。他准备好底漆时，他说其中一面墙开始对他说话，说——
I hate to tell you this, but I'm really treatment resistant.
我讨厌告诉你这一点，但我真的很“治疗抗拒”。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
[MUSIC - MARY J. BLIGE, "THERAPY"]
[音乐 - 玛丽·布莱姬，《Therapy》]